start off this hour with an eye on
California I am how are you hi I'm doing
great so for excited to be talking to
you guys today
discovered you like two weeks ago Wow
unbelievable I know I wish I would have
discovered you earlier hi John how are
you
I'm outstanding and I didn't exist
before two weeks ago so we're just
discovering each other for the first
time that's excellent question for you
guys my husband and I have a total debt
of about $500,000 and 32 of that debt is
my student loans and then the rest of
that is pretty much my husband and he is
the one that makes the most income but
it's because he travels overseas what is
the time so we're both in the oil
industry what does he make he makes 250
is his gross base salary how long's
you've been minding that how long have
you been making that two years okay
so put them in my base salary is 120 so
pretty much if we want to get out of our
dead we started the 14 day trial of the
Financial Peace University and we're
projected to pay our date off in April
of 2024 but that means that my husband
to renew his contract for another 3
years which pretty much already put
hardship in our marriage and we were
actually thinking about getting a
divorce
last year so we started counseling
Christian counseling in January of this
year but I had already decided to sell
the house in case we did get a divorce
and we did go through with it
so we made about a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars in profit of that
house in my husband wanted to go
back to school he'll he already has a
master's and now he wanted to get
executive education for $50,000 I also
wanted to go back to school and get my
master's which was going to be a hundred
K plus living expenses and hopefully in
eighteen months out potentially have a
better income so right now we're sort of
on baby step number two and we're
wondering what we should do with the 80
K that we have leftover off the profit
of the house should we do baby step
three first should we invest in another
home so that maybe we can make potential
money in a few years is it worth to pay
off our debt in April putting our
marriage at risk it's sort of like a lot
of things going on plus I'm having a
surgery next are you both asking that
all of these questions yeah no we're
both here we're both here together we're
both men we're actually starting the
Financial Peace University today
together okay yeah
witnesses contract run up with his
current the overseas work in one year
one year okay I a profound like way far
away that's too long you're making a
combined 370 that's a to quote day
that's a huge shovel to get to dig out
of this $500,000
I mean 250,000 a year on 500 makes it go
away in two years and you'd have to live
on a measly 120 right you're breaking my
heart what what do you think a $50,000
executive certificate from Harvard's
gonna get you it's more for the
opportunity to probably change
industries okay could we say we are the
oil industry so it's kind of easier
right now I just applied and got
accepted so I'm not too sure so that's
what we kind of understand and Anna
either your voice got real deep or you
just handed the phone off the husband is
that right okay so I
have an executive certificate from
Harvard and somebody else paid for it
for me not an employer that I negotiated
and they paid for it for me it was a
great experience I did get smarter it's
not worth $50,000 especially if not
$50,000 let me reframe that it's not
worth borrowing $50,000 for the big H is
important and powerful and it put me in
contact with great people all that stuff
dude you've got a half a million dollar
screaming emergency staring you in the
face and y'all have got to get that
figured out
I don't like blaming geography while it
can be a contributing factor to this
idea that this is why your marriage had
issues so give me a give me a bigger
context on a greater context more
specifically what was wrong with your
marriage so pretty much I don't know
it's like my husband just concentrates
and work a lot and then he puts a
hundred percent and working sets
everything else aside okay
and mmm like being this scent that makes
it a lot easier for him to do and just
like sort of shut me out of his life
okay so are y'all still seeing a
therapist now we are okay so if you're
working with the marriage counselor and
that's where y'all have landed that that
you need to make a job transition that's
great on honor that relationship and the
work y'all have done there I I'm just I
don't think you should get any more
student loan debt at all whatsoever ever
much less with this giant on fire
situation you have right now and
something tells me if you're you are the
caliber person that's got Pepperdine is
an extraordinary school UT Austin and
I'm from Texas that's an extraordinary
school you're smart enough to have
landed a 250k gig right now you're smart
enough to land another you can pivot and
and take that skill and transfer it to
another place so I don't know it would
be subject to your marriage counselors
approval this idea but I think for 24
months if you increased communication in
he was overseas and you increased lots
of collaboration all working towards a
central goal of cleaning his debt up but
do you feel like to have no debt and
what price would you pay emotionally
what price would you pay
since wise to have no debt all right
what are you willing to do I'm not
willing sacrifice your marriage on that
altar okay but but I know that I'm with
John geography doesn't necessarily solve
that it's lack of shared vision like a
shared goals like a communication a lot
of those kinds of things show up in that
so if I'm in your shoes if I can get the
marriage counselor to give me a process
that you both agree to for increasing
communication collaboration shared goals
I'm gonna work my buns off for two years
and be 100% debt-free you change
everything and then you make a lot of
different decisions oh oh by the way we
meant we got another hundred thousand we
can throw at this debt and today so
we're only dealing with four hundred
right now you've only got to do two
hundred a year for two years now now
we're gonna do it 19 months at the
latest you know there's no way this is
2024